[Music]
soldiers
the second polish war has begun at
tilsit
russia pledged an eternal alliance with
france and war on england
today her oath is broken she refuses all
explanations of her strange conduct
unless the french
eagles re-cross the rhine fate
draws russia on her destiny must be
accomplished does she then think us
degenerate
are we no longer the soldiers of
austerlitz she places us between
dishonor and war
can our choice be in doubt forward then
across the niemann and let us carry the
war
onto her own soil
[Music]
the emperor orders the marshals and
generals in command of army corps of
divisions and of brigades and colonels
to take all measures for maintaining the
strictest discipline
and for preventing the disorders that
are beginning to ravage the country
i'm just in the heat is oppressive and
there is much dust which is
rather tiring the whole of the enemy's
army was here it was under orders to
fight
but didn't dare to we had to force our
way into smolensk
the russian army which is very
discouraged and dissatisfied
is retreating in the direction of moscow
after having for 18 months constantly
refused to give me an explanation your
majesty has at last
through your minister placed a summons
before me to evacuate prussia
as a preliminary to an understanding a
few days later this
minister asked for his passports and
three times repeated
that demand from that moment i was in a
state
of war with your majesty i pity
the wickedness of those who could give
your majesty such advice
but however it may be never shall
russia use such language to france
war has therefore begun between us god
himself
cannot undo what is done but i shall
always be ready to listen
to proposals for peace and when your
majesty really attempts to cut loose
from the influence of men who are the
enemies
of your family of your glory and of that
of your empire
you will always find me of the same mind
and of equal friendship
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan's been a fantastic supporter of
the work of me and my brother
over at history time for a while now and
with their support this year we've got a
sequel to japan and the west coming
as well as more full-length
documentaries and also
an entirely new channel to look forward
to
and this week's recommendation is a
great companion piece to our last few
videos
napoleon an origin story of sorts it
charts napoleon's remarkable rise to
power
a fantastic well-acted watch those that
don't know magellan is essentially a
netflix for documentaries with the
largest range of history stuff
anywhere and over 3 000 documentaries in
total
it's the perfect way to widen your
knowledge on a mountain of topics
in 2021 so click on the link in the
description for an exclusive
month-long free trial for voices of the
past viewers
thanks
[Music]
after throwing up earthworks batteries
and readouts and after announcing their
intention of defending them
the enemy as usual have shown the white
feather
we are now in this town which is sizable
that is to say has
eight to ten churches the country is
good and people say it remains fertile
all the way to moscow
the heat is excessive the weather
splendid
reports state the enemy are resolved to
make a stand
at viasma we have reached viasma
the enemy continue their retreat to
moscow
reply to general giamini that it is
absurd to say there is no bread when we
have 25
tons of flour a day instead of
complaining let him be up at four in the
morning
proceeding to the mills into the baking
ovens in person
and bake thirty thousand rations of
bread every
day if he goes to sleep or if he whines
he will get
nothing we shall soon have a battle that
will eat up an enormous amount of powder
and supplies
how are we to replenish our stores must
we send empty wagons back to vilna
that would mean a month or six weeks
before we could get them to the front
again
right to officers commanding army corps
that we may lose many men daily because
there is no
system in the supply service it is
urgently necessary that they should take
measures in concert with their colonels
to put an end to the state of things
that threatens the army with destruction
every day the enemy pick up several
hundred prisoners
during the 20 years in which i have
commanded french armies i have never
seen the commissariat service so
hopelessly bad
there is no one the men sent out here
have no ability and
no experience
the battle of borrodino was the most
glorious most difficult and most
creditable
operation of war carried out by the
gauls of which either ancient or modern
history
makes mention dauntless heroes murat
nay poniatowski it is to you the
glorious dew
what great what splendid deeds history
might place on record
how we charged and sabred the gunners
and their guns
the heroic devotion of mont brun who
found death in the midst of their glory
and our brave infantry at the most
critical moment
not in need of their general steadying
voice but calling out to him
it's all right your soldiers have sworn
they will conquer
and they will
we'd marched but a few miles from
machisk when we were astonished to find
ourselves notwithstanding our proximity
to one of the great capitals of the
world
in the midst of a sandy and absolutely
desert waste the army crossed the place
with difficulty
our horses were harassed and worn out
with hunger and thirst
for water was as scarce as forage the
men
suffered very much we arrived
at moscow in the evening
[Music]
the beautiful and splendid city of
moscow
no longer exists rostopchin
has burnt it down 400 incendiaries have
been caught in the act all
declared they were starting fires by
order of the governor
and the chief of the police they were
shot
the fire seems to have died out at last
three quarters of the houses have gone
a quarter remain such conduct is
atrocious and
useless was the object to deprive us of
a few resources
well those resources were in sellers
that the fire did not reach
even then the destruction of one of the
most beautiful cities in the world
the work of centuries for so slight an
object
is inconceivable if i suppose that any
things were being done under the orders
of your majesty i should not write this
letter but i hold it impossible that
anyone
with the high principles of your majesty
such heart
such right feelings could have
authorized these excesses
unworthy as they are of a great
sovereign
and a great nation
i have conducted the war against your
majesty with no animosity
a line written to me before or after the
last battle would have stopped by march
and i would gladly have foregone the
advantage of entering moscow
if anything of our old friendship
remains
your majesty will take this letter in
good part
[Music]
despite the poet's art all the imaginary
details of the burning of troy can never
equal
the reality of that of moscow
the city was built of wood the wind was
very strong
all the fire engines had been removed
it was literally an ocean of fire
the enemies movement shows clearly that
they are expecting reinforcements from
the army of moldavia
to march against them would be to
operate in the line of their reserves
and without any supporting positions
moscow now that is burnt down and
deserted by its inhabitants is of no use
to us
it cannot even accommodate our sick and
wounded
if the army is to fall back on smolensk
is it wise to follow up the enemy and to
run the risk
while executing a movement that would
look like a retreat
of losing several thousand men in the
face of an army that knows the country
that has many spies and a large force of
light cavalry
if we should decide to fall back so as
to take up winter quarters in poland
is it the best cause to retire directly
by the same road
by which we came
i find it hard to believe that we need
45 days to evacuate the wounded from
moscow
if i calculate that even if we do
nothing in those 45 days part of them
will die part of them will get well we
should therefore only have to evacuate
those that remained
and experience shows that three months
after a battle only one-sixth
of the wounded remain reckoning on six
thousand there would therefore be at the
end of
three months only one thousand to move
my purpose is to keep control of the
line of operations
and to evacuate the wounded
the army is in motion tomorrow we shall
decide to blow up the kremlin
and to march by kaluga or by viasma
so as to arrive before severe weather
sets in and get into winter quarters
all is going well
in fact the natives are amazed at the
weather of the last three weeks
we are having the sunshine and lovely
days of the trip to fontainebleau
the army is in a very rich comedy that
is comparable with the finest of france
and germany
since my last letter to you our
situation has become worse
ice and frost of near zero have killed
off nearly all our horses
say thirty thousand we've been compelled
to burn nearly 300 pieces of artillery
and an immense quantity of transport
wagons the cold has
greatly increased the number of
stragglers the cossacks have turned
to account our absolute want of cavalry
and of artillery
to harass us and cut our communications
i've just crossed the berezina but the
river is full of floating ice and our
bridges are therefore very insecure
the cold is very severe the army is
excessively fatigued
i've received your letter of which there
is not a word of french news nor of
spanish
this makes two weeks during which i have
heard nothing and i'm in the dark about
everything
the army is numerous but in a frightful
state of
disbandment we need two weeks to reform
the men into regiments and where can we
get two weeks
cold and privation have broken up the
army we shall soon reach vilna
can we stay there yes if we can hold on
for eight days but if we are attacked
during the first eight days
it is doubtful whether we can stay there
food food food
otherwise there are no horrors which
this undisciplined mob is not capable of
wreaking
on the city if one hundred thousand
rations of bread are not awaiting us in
vilna
i am sorry for the city an abundance of
supplies is the only thing that can
bring back discipline the army is
horribly worn out
this is the 45th day's march
the roads were covered with ice the
horses were dying every night not in
hundreds but in thousands
especially the french and german horses
more than 50
000 horses died in a few days our
cavalry was dismounted our artillery and
transport had no
teams without cavalry we could not risk
a battle
we were compelled to march so as not to
be forced into a battle
which we wish to avoid because of our
shortness of ammunition
the enemy marching in the footsteps of
the frightful calamity that had
overtaken the french army
tried to profit by it all our columns
were surrounded by cossacks who
like the arabs in the desert picked up
every cartel wagon that laid behind
this contemptible cavalry which only
knows how to shout and couldn't ride
down so much as a company of light
infantry
became formidable from the force of
circumstances
[Music]
it may be concluded from what was being
said that the army needs to
re-establish its discipline to be
re-equipped to remount its cavalry
its artillery and its transport
yet during all these events the emperor
constantly managed
in the midst of the guard the cavalry
commanded by the duke of istria
the infantry by the duke of dantag our
cavalry was so reduced that it became
necessary to form all the officers
who were still mounted into four
companies of 150 men
each generals acted as captains and
colonels as corporals
this sacred squadron commanded by
general groshi and under the orders of
the king of naples
kept the closest watch over the emperor
his majesty's health has never been
better
[Music]
you